just five minutes on memory will teach
you how to use okay thank you
his teaches a bit too much for that okay
so hello so I'm silver first oh yeah I
want to thanks a few times to
Valentinian Philip where the main
organizers of the despite at conference
i joined the burden pi data group a
little while ago and they were very
welcoming so thanks to both of them and
they also encourage me to give this talk
so and by that the berlin by data
community and to all of you for
attending i hope i will you'll be happy
with the tutorial and that you will
learn um so few words about me maybe I
yes I thought I tell you I live in
Berlin you know and I thought it's
boring so I know I looked I thought
outside just living the universe you
know it's a bit more interesting I
thought how that's like getting boring
too and then there's apparently these
multiverse or this in physics well I
found that the ultimate multiverse is
very cool theory and invite you to check
it out if you have some time some point
now by i live in berlin I'm originally
from Canada montrell but I've been
living in Berlin working as a software
engineer for three years in of a
bachelor in computer science with sort
of a kind of minor in physics the
university didn't have a former minor
major kind of thing in physics well
major yes but not minor by the many
courses in physics was I think I was
heavily involved in all kinds of
undergraduate research assistantship
which is kind of why I'm interested in
data science because I'm not a data
scientist I'm more just like ordinary
software engineer but in the course of
my studies I was involved in some
computational high energy physics
research assistantship with some finer
and mathematical packages called fine
arts and then some NLP automatic text
summarization thing but then from then
when I started working I've just been
working with python django
elasticsearch RabbitMQ it's kind of
standard tools that are used nowadays
attic and then I got also a bit into dev
ops so Saul stack and then lately
daugher a quick note about this the
DevOps work is like because that that's
the angle I'm approaching this whole
thing it's like when you work as a
software developer and many companies
you're a bit left s when she startups I
think you're left to yourself like I you
know here's we have a sprint you need to
do these tasks and you need to produce
and all that and it's often the cases
that I add the dev environment is sort
of kind of working and you ask the
colleague is like I don't know for me I
did this command it works now and they
don't touch the virtual machine hoping
it stays like that I've seen that a lot
actually and it was last year then the
guy was responsible for our VMs was
impaired until leave and my computer had
a hardware crash and I just had to
install the whole development
environment on a new machine I was kind
of a bit stuck and then I decided to
learn how to do it myself and I use
vagrant and virtualbox and Saul stack
and since then I'm kind of hooked on
that because what it gives you is like
you really feel autonomous at least that
that's what for me it brought in that
whatever happens I can focus on my
development task and if my development
environment somehow is broken or
something I sort of how know how to fix
it Plus this knowledge is useful even to
to help people in staging and production
DevOps people so I think it's a really
worthwhile investment to learn these
tools so the next thing now is is this
tutorial obviously will be focusing on
dr. the goal of the tutorial is
obviously just to learn docker to learn
to use it and I'm also a beginner with
docker maybe just using it for a month
and a half or so on a part-time basis so
that's really the focus I had initially
a long term go sort of like for this
tutorial to at the end have a notebook
fully set up that runs in a container
plus using let's say something like
blaze and you have a few other
containers in which you would have
you of these data storage technologies
like whether it's spark a database and
just to play around with that but I
think it's going to be a bit too much
for this tutorial so but we'll see
depending on how it goes and you're
always welcome to interrupt me and ask
me question at any time I'm fine with
that the tutorial approach this is very
important there's something I called it
fineman's Babylonian mathematics if you
look this up I don't know if I'm going
to be able to go on the internet but it
looks like it it's a video that thing is
like it's every Fineman Richard Feynman
he gave some lectures in the 60s about
it's something like called a messenger
lecture at Cornell and it was a
Microsoft day they bought the rights and
now they have this thing called the tuva
project and they have all the lectures
available it's also on YouTube and this
is just an excerpt in which it was
something called a character of the
physical law and heat there's a talk
where he talks about the relationship
between mathematics and physics and if
you listen to that the gist is that
there's a point where you mentioned
something what we call the Greek
mathematics versus Babylonian
mathematics and it's it's it's like very
interesting to see his point of view
that what in brief what it is it's like
Greek mathematics was known like that
they built on fundamental axioms so now
we're learning docker that will be the
analogy here is like okay what is darker
you know it's okay we're talking about
linux kernel lxc or whatever you know
and then you just build your knowledge
from that up okay the in contrast to
Babylonian mathematics where you just
like okay I know maybe how to use darker
for that I know this part of darker and
you just like like a puzzle make your
way around and at some point in the end
you may arrive at the same place but you
there's no correct path and now i'm
mentioning this because in a tutorial
like that in 90 minutes and
it's a short amount of time plus I'm not
skilled enough and insists and men and
DevOps to explain you what docker is
from the ground up like really like
fundamentally how operating system works
and so on so the approach I'm taking is
just we're learning to use docker on the
common line doing things doing examples
and from that around that some knowledge
will incremental e grow you know but
there's no like correct back like
working again from fundamental actions
that's why I pointed out this this
tutorial project finding the building in
mathematics and invite you to look at
the video it's I think it's very
interesting because he egos and very
precise details about this compare
reason a refined line of this tutorial
so dr. installation docker hub will talk
about the club which is kind of github
if you want for dr. images talk about
docker images docker containers and then
linking the containers together managing
data on containers and darker compose if
we have enough time so look for instance
what is darker you know I look this up
and this is what Tucker says on their
website which is like darker is an open
platform for developers and citizen mins
to build ship and run distributed
applications okay ah I mean that's why
you know Babylonian mathematics for me
that's like whatever I mean it's like
because otherwise if you really want one
one way to to maybe that it makes more
sense that I saw someone that what they
say is that darker it sent boxes a
process so the unix or linux process
that's if you're running a whatever like
the ipython notebook or a web server
whiskey server then your sent box in
that process and you're able to have
many of these processes sandbox and
using sharing some resources of the base
operating system but that's not the
direction in which I wish to go right
now again so I want us to practice using
it so okay installation so who has not
installed it let's say and wants to
install it okay
you're on the mac and so maybe then it's
kissed elation so if you're on a Mac
like there's two main ways that you can
go about fundamentally Indiana will be
like running on a virtual box so you
need probably to have a virtual box I
guess install right it installs it for
you I guess or something okay you see if
you saw little box okay all right okay
I'm sorry I evidence so far Wassel okay
but did you try just brew install a boot
to docker because actually this works
you didn't work so did you go on this
website that were there and you tried
following the instructions and that work
is a good one yeah you're fine so you
guys are fun at out I go on yeah just a
quick note maybe about that that if
you're like a small trick if you're on
the mac or some other machine where you
don't have the ochre right that like a
quick parenthesis right like the thing
is like for linux it works like natively
because the this thing doctor is based
on Alexei as far as I understood which
is specific to linux and mac OS x the
operating system does not have that so
that's why we need to go around that
using server very lightweight virtual
machine you can use docker machine as
well where you create a darker machine
like that but i don't want to confuse
you but then just two and this will
instantiate a virtual machine with
darker bootstrapped on it and then you
ssh into it and is you're just like in a
linux environment and you can then use
darker machine that's like another
ah snot Sandra know about this shadow oh
ok yeah all right ok so installation
check the installation let's do that
just to be sure I guess I don't know if
I don't think matters much for a
tutorial but one point six point two is
if some one of the latest 1i think so
just darker help you know you can check
so many comments key everyone is okay
next thing docker hub to host public
docker images to made it image or a
builder thematically if you hook them up
to let's say github or bitbucket repo I
mean this is cool you know I don't know
if you've looked at that I encourage you
to if you haven't you can signing you
can actually do that I think even
through the common line just by doing
darker login and then you enter your
credentials there or otherwise
okay because one nice thing with with
docker is that you you can share the
images you know which is okay let's say
we search an image so there are many
many many images already publicly
available that you can benefit from so
and by registering to get this docker
hub ting what you can also do and if you
hook up your images to a what would in
the end what happens is that you you set
up a let me say github repo in which you
put dr. a docker file and then you you
link it to dr. hub and it will each time
you update the recoil will update build
the darker image for you but I mentioned
maybe more later about that but if you
can register there that would be nice
and if internet is working enough then
we may be able to try it okay docker
images okay without getting into this is
that they have a nice by the way Dockers
documentation is really good I think so
at any time when you're on your own
you're wondering like I think it's the
to go place before I'll swear if and
then maybe so they have fun since they
explain here a bit like how you know
what doctor is a bit like you know with
the these concept of images that are
built on top of each other but so that's
the theory now okay common line docker
images
so I don't know if you have if you have
used already you can list images you
have on your system if you have not used
it before you won't see anything
Constance if I just show you okay so no
images they're like something called
intermediate images so if you want to
list intermediate images you can use the
flag minus a or minus minus all will
show you many more images there's these
non images which are not sure exactly
its intermediate I think they are used
to build it the main image that you have
yes yeah we'll do that in a few minutes
yeah yeah there are many way we can go
into the order so let's do first like
searching images so right you can search
the I think by default the way it is
it's like okay dr. works with this
registry where you can search store
images and retrieve images from by
default it's docker hub but you can set
that yourself in your organization if
you want to use another kind of registry
it's possible to do so but right now
we'll just work with docker hub so let's
say we want to search images yet
yes that's what I'm saying I think it's
it's even open source it's a and it's
it's a jungle I think based app and you
can yes you can host your own doctor hub
registry all right you're on docker
registry and you can call it whatever
you want but yeah it's possible yeah so
say we search for Python and just but
now because the internet thing here is
there's one thing we've talked her up
it's kind of slow even with the good
internet connection so here's probably
going to be a bit rough so I had
prepared some examples so you can try
that I mean let's try it for fun but
yeah it's not going to work here that's
unfortunate but really okay bye doesn't
matter me I did it before so I don't
care so well you can try these out now
seriously do it because I mean this is
like so if it works for you then you can
you can certain next thing is like
there's some search options I'm going
into the details here maybe it's not
necessarily like obviously if you're
just using it at work there are many
things that you don't maybe mind but
this is useful to know I think so this
will only displays at least at the
because the docker images on docker hub
are like ranked with stars so you can
say okay I just want to see images who
have at least let's say 20 stars one
hundred stars so if you try it for
instance for a Python I think I have
some example here like let's say stars
equals 15 or minus s 15 for short now
let me soon
okay Mia does not work so then you can
say no trunk this will like not truncate
the output that means that the now I
won't see the the search the container
ID the image ID which is shorten will be
a thing oh no on this is the description
the description of the image you'll get
the full text automated it's like some
images or flagged as being automated
that means the the build of them is
automated it will tell you if you just
want to search images that have an
automatic bill now the interesting part
with that I don't know why they did it
like that but it's like so there are
some darker images on the unlocker hub
that are flagged as official so they are
maintained by the darker community or
company and from what it looks like when
one of the darker image is like is
official it's not autumn tomato matic
the build is not automatic so if you
filter out like only for automated
images then you won't get the official
images so I don't know but they seem to
be no way to just I just want to search
official images so now I cannot show you
me because I'm kind of but if you just
do like that search automated then
you'll just get the official image of
python that is maintained by darker
itself so we are quick notes that's what
doctor says about it the official
represented or created set of dr.
repositories that are promoted on docker
hub why yes ah maybe a quick note for
those using darker butta darker on the
Mac you're using it sometimes you have
to restart it if you switch network so I
think maybe that's why I mean it's not I
was not working
okay but I know it's there so if I good
this there's think that's yeah official
repository is on docker hub and then and
if you really into it you really want to
look at it there's the repo you can even
contribute to these official images on
github like where they're maintained
with the guidelines on how to contribute
and so on you know this is quite
involved I would say but so if you're
curious and you want to contribute to
official images you it's possible okay
dr. Poole okay now so searching images
sorry it's kind of slow on foot but they
so searching images now you can pull
images so let's say well maybe just yeah
probably but I mean it's like that not
yet what you can do the example I have
you pull busybox I mean try it I mean
that's why not this box is a very small
minimalist machine for embedded linux so
just try it I mean and that's i'll pray
matter is so the search is also now okay
um okay so then you can list you know I
don't know me I'm can I fear closer okay
now I pulled us a visit boxing
also abusing here because I already have
it but okay that this is why the
internet is like blasting right now okay
so then you can list images and you can
see is there a way that I can move that
ass not mine does it make sense if I'm
not just fun okay bye right ok ok ok ok
ok ok cool so thing like you know
quickly subjects sometimes when we do
something as fish at work maybe there's
lots of thing we overlook like because
we don't need it and later like I cannot
find it and it was like right in your
face in the beginning when you learned a
thing so just like when you do docker
images like what it shows you you know
so for the clearer screening ok the
repository name busybox the tag so yet
images are tagged so they can be at
version as if we later we could look at
images like Python so they'll be tagged
with the Python version three point four
point three three point four two point
seven point nine or whatsoever the image
ID at the time it was created and a
virtual size of it ok now what do I have
next ah yeah the so dude run this docker
images you can do minus ei for short
or minus minus all if you want to so it
shows you these what da from what I read
in the documentation these are
intermediate images and now a Babylonian
mathematics I will not explain you what
this is because I don't really know yeah
but still I mean it's useful to know
because as you can see it has a virtual
size and yesterday I was playing around
I mean this is very small but if you
like let's say I've like some kind of
sci-fi stack related image it can be
quite big Alec 1 2 gigabytes and then
you see if you do minus minus all I can
show you on this one ok this is let's
say I'm listing my images and you see I
have like two gigabytes here one since I
Python sites i surprised that now if I
do all and let's say oh I'll be a freak
out my mice myspace on my and you'll see
it as bunch of these none and some have
like yeah 1.2 77 gigabyte and I don't I
think they're like they support the main
image let's say the side price tag I
Python but that's as far as I'll go yeah
yeah so these are right there used to
build your yeah yeah yeah yeah yes yeah
you're correct yeah so if you delete the
image these none will get removed or if
you try to remove one of the usable
probably complaints that I cannot be
need it because but yeah I mean let's
stick listen to the busy box you know we
just install that and then you can see
so these two like Exxon is saying like
they're used to build the busybox like
yeah that's correct nothing that's a
good example
your husband the second one with the end
of each epoch see when happy install
again and you may not get another non
image which is built on top of that he
is unnamed doing yeah so something like
that right yeah yeah so let's say we
take busybox right okay if we want to
drill down this so we have busybox not
none twice right so that will be if we
use this image a bit that will be like
let's say that's it that will be three
none or whatever but so busy box will be
this writable container that's said and
none none and then let whatever that's
yeah good okay next I yeah you can pull
all them now let's kill the internet so
you can do or minus ei for short so
because yeah images are our tag well I
mean the thing is like you can see it
that thing if you know so we do it so
busy well we won't abuse will just do
with busy box so now I will pull all of
the busybox images I mean this can be
useful you know let's say you just I
don't know you're testing bunch of stuff
and you need to make sure that they run
on a multiple Python version and you
want to pull all the images for Python
because you want to set yourself to work
meanwhile you go make coffee or whatever
so then you do pull all you know the
Python images this maybe take a while no
even for a small so let's leave it there
okay I won't wait but after that once
this is done if you do docker images to
list them you you will see the other
versions okay now your question it's
very slow response i'm sorry dr. rmi
that's the way to delete the image so
the plan with this tutorial I was
assuming a relatively correct internet
connection when I build the tutorial so
it was that then we delete some of these
images that we just installed with
busybox but yeah well let's do it I mean
you can delete whatever but if you only
have busybox will be gone you know so I
don't know it's like a mmm well I'll
show you on I don't want to delete
something moving right now but maybe
yeah let's keep this theoretically just
a turtle thing because if you delete
your stuff it's not a good idea giving
the internet but that's the way to let's
see I first help maybe darker or my- so
just remove one or more images you can
force and then you can I don't know what
the note prune is exactly do not delete
on type parents well this is what it is
but I've not used it so that's the way
to delete images some example 30 theory
here to you loose your docker images
let's say yeah that was a thing that's
it with busybox well if you have them if
for you at work like pulling them on
then you can try let's say you dealing
you can speed the way you do it you
specify the container i add the image
item so let's say which one is the FFA
f80 4rm ifaf it so far and will untag it
and then it deletes d i guess these are
the non images that did the one that it
uses to build
I think then you would see that it's
gone see if of now it's not working
there's a way to list only the numeric
IDs of the images now why would you want
to do that I'll show you that's clean up
trick that I saw is this guy John Willis
he works at doctor and he has tutorial
on youtubes on tutorials on YouTube and
they're really good I think they work
from the ground up up to more advanced
topics so if you have time to spare and
you want to know more i would recommend
so I saw this trick by him on the
tutorial so you can like if you have
many images and you want to get rid of
them all at once you can do like that so
that it will just passage there will be
a list of ID's and then you can delete
them all
just kill that ah you see it managed to
pull one I think but let's say i'll try
it here rmi can you see it so darker
well first okay as you can see it just
lists the ids now we want to leave them
all which is so now I've no more images
nothing so that's the way to delete
images who pulling some darker images I
was very full of hope ah yeah did anyone
of you do that yesterday maybe at home
or at who all right okay so docker PS
now if this is to list the containers
now if i go and the one here it will be
nothing because there's nothing and you
can also do minus a all because there's
like a it will show you docker PS will
show you the active containers and when
you do minus a will show you also the
containers that are stopped but so I was
now let's run something so then this
docker PS will make more sense now run
is a has many options so first I'm going
super step by step okay we'll take the
Jupiter notebook for those who have it
if you don't have it then just take
busybox or whatever you have because it
does not matter for this example the
next two three four but let's see three
four examples
it does not matter whatever you use um
so yeah you can just do that done dr.
run Jupiter notebook let's say or visit
box whatever you have nothing it's not
working you know not joking but if you
do dr. PS nothing do- a ah oh I have
some more stuff me sorry now I'm
polluting the mmm thing this okay now
this may hey look a bit overkill but I'm
going very step by step because hey how
do I explain that but ok let's let's
keep it like that so alright so what we
do is like what happens like the
container run and it just exited because
it depends on the command that the image
has if the image as a command when it's
built some and this one is just setting
a bin sh and it just exited while Big
Bash ok yeah ok chose you you see so
container
so right you have container ID image
command so big bash created okay exited
about a minute ago the pores and the
names name okay so we could delete this
container to which is darker RM and you
can pass either the name or the
container ID so do you need it darker
you know okay so that's this now we can
run an interactive mode so the flag is
minus I for short so what this says like
keep a steady is standard in open even
if not attached so let's do that you can
just do minus I if you want to save some
typing so run minus r QQ now it's like
whoa okay what's going on but if you
type in let's say LS oh ok good w do oh
sorry sorry sorry so it's gonna be here
come on you just leave a container right
yes well we'll come back to it yeah but
yes it a if the know if the container is
running you need to stop it first and
then if it stopped then you can delete
it but we'll come back to that so okay
now let me hold on let's restart this
one so okay we do done doc if you can
everyone see clearly yeah it's good
enough now I can appear like i'm showing
you these flags like one by one but you
see it's kind of useful to know so minus
I what it does it creates an interactive
opens a standard input so now you are in
the container actually and we can
execute commands
it's a okay where am i okay for this
Python hi it's kind of cool you know I
can even start ipython anything yeah
okay okay so that's an interactive mode
but this is not may be very a there's
better wait you can yeah we could delete
it as well yeah okay here maybe um doc
now have a few okay i think many very
often like we want people don't you
don't just run in and attract okay here
RM if you want so to answer your
question a bit here like yet so to
delete the container at you but it the
container needs to be stopped okay the
other one minus TTYL and then we'll come
back so they usually if you do an
interactive mode you also combine with
with this minus T which allocated pseudo
TTYL our terminal so we can try it now
just without the interactive just for a
fun of it so run minus T the container
the image now we're in a like a proper
terminal if you want of the container
that's big enough
but now there's a probability does not
respond because it's not interactive so
you can't so I have to kill it so the
way to do it properly if you really want
to have an interactive session and to be
in the container and to execute commands
it's like that so you passed right you
guys so so you pass minus I mean the
short form is minus IT you could do
minus minus interactive space minus
minus TTYL sure so now the same thing we
have learned the container ok let's say
you're again because these are like sand
boxes one way to see it if you want to
okay you're experimenting but you don't
want each time to delete the container
for whatever reason so you can pass the
the flag minus minus RM it will
automatically remove the container when
you exit ok so only 30 minutes to the
tutorial really I'm going to sleep where
are the containers now man let's keep
going all right okay who wants me to
speed up because I went through this
already ok so you can I can
automatically have the container to be
removed you can try it dr. run that at
the track and then when you can just do
it quickly minus 18 whatever you want
now making typos because I want to go
tails okay so I want the container if
you exit container is well it's not this
one I was another one but it should be
gone no that's the thing yeah notta but
that's that was the the point of this
command did yes exactly that's why this
minus minus RM flag is useful is that it
will automatically remove the container
once you're done with it when you exited
or if the container exist by itself it
will be removed a provincial from the
ocean sigma naught data well we assume
let's say right now the in this context
like if I understand your question like
the the virtual machine is sort of like
you can consider like as though you're
just on a base Linux system because
obviously if you go and destroyed it
that's this vm i'm using right now the
whole thing is gone you I like just like
fight through a computer away in the
trash but let's say if we consider a
virtual machine to be a real machine
this container is removed from that
machine yeah give you cover famous topic
container put I don't know yeah yeah
yeah I think you can attach even when
it's running but if it stopped I don't
know actually um okay yeah I'll keep
going because actually I'm not sure
about this question so I'll leave it it
so
okay so let's let's do some real stuff
now you can give a container a name so
you pass name and you give it then it's
easier after you can delete the
container by its name and you can do
other stop-start it by its name and so
on so in this example called the
notebook let's just end be four short
and then you can do that now and I'll go
through dr. foul okay that's the
interesting part a so we can now yeah
okay let's using a simple example so
okay docker images are built from docker
file actually so if you want to build
your own image yourself but usually it's
you'll extend from an existing base
image or an existing image which you can
find on da club so this is an example of
a simple docker file that we extend from
you book too I mean if you're a really
fast typer and you want to type this you
can and then you will build it or you
can get clone my repo but now you can
give it a shot let's give me one second
here
if you go to github and you can clone
that repo I'm sorry I didn't share that
yesterday I was not there so you can
give it a try don't know if the internet
connection will work but i would say
maybe is just spend 23 minutes right now
and try to clone this repo if it works
then you'll have there's much of darker
files there it you can just already use
for the keep going so maybe if you can
just spend just clone this and then
we'll go back to this docker file that
does anyone need you have it okay cool
why not maybe leave the update maybe the
app get update is not necessary because
it will be long i can t shirt coming
which in each opens at this is a foul so
if you have cloned the repo you just
open it in a text editor if you have not
clone the report and you can just open
any file and the file is is named docker
file yeah okay
so that's the unique the by convention
the darker the darker file is called
docker file with a capital D so that's
the way you need to name the file that
ok all right ok which is created with
such paths so is there such a file
behind it too yes every images is like
that yeah no I'm sorry i'll still in the
screen for those who are typing it but
the fight on image you bone to image
they have something called from scratch
which you use but you can all this you
can do if you go to dr. hub and you
select an image and then somewhere on
the website you can there's a link where
you can see the docker file that is
behind yeah this one yes yeah you can
use Santa less you can use a no I just
mean like you do Afghan Saul Python I
mean we also download it to spite the
bucket and you can connect these two so
you use pipe in front of her I'm sorry I
don't understand doctor if you already
have the option right yeah it so we
already have like doc file it's not my
driver's license or anything or look
it's not my job
yeah good are you kidding okay for those
who have jupiter notebook you can even
go this will even be quicker I'm sorry I
should have shown that be if we just
want to run a notebook right now I have
an image that runs notebook you can just
do that this will be quicker to build
but that's that I'm not sure where at
which scream do you want to see now for
who's doing what so I I was personally
just happy to tell us a bit about how to
use dr. what he's in for I love you at
first our doctor because yeah I can get
probably started with all the commands
yeah yeah sure imitation but getting to
the burglars perspective five
documentation is with Hassan be happy
about this all right now my did the
usage of darker I do is right now just
on the side if you want but the goal for
me is to then move to use that for
development reasons so when I need to
work for development when I need to
develop code for work for my development
environment like sand boxes but then the
thing is that these images once if you
test code in one container and it runs
as expected then then you you can carry
this on to staging environment
production environment that's the kind
of ID in brief does that answer you so
maybe if I do patent about them now I
usually set up a virtual environment and
click install yes yes yes yes and yes I
think I but a feels a lot of people who
are using docker account using it as an
unconscious Bushman mamas they set up
their their OS here and then they
install the patent and z's into it so
they have an isolation yes and that is
running more smooth than that of Ashland
but has to be isolated with strange
paths at home but how do you how do you
maintain those environment for example
if you if you want to change versions of
those packages how would you do that or
you need to rebuild the image each time
if you change something but yeah I mean
that's a that's a tingle why are
emphasized at the beginning of the
torial this kind of Fineman Babylonian
mathematics thing there's many angle at
which you can approach that and the with
this tutorial I wanted to do more of a
hands-on if even if you don't know why
the hell am I using docker right now in
this room now I mean it does not matter
to me right now that's the approach i'm
taking i'm actually like learning to use
it and discovering how it works and
where it will be useful in which kind of
type of workflows i think there are many
different answers to that like depending
on your needs but an immediate need i
can see is that if a new developer join
the team and you need to the person
needs to join into your to contribute
new code you know if you can provide
them dr. images to just get started to
have the necessary environment with the
necessary architecture you know you may
need like it I don't know all kinds of
database this and this and that some
kind of queuing system and you have
these containers and they're like set up
to get to work together I think you can
save a lot of time and there you have
reusability as well but I mean that will
be the short answer you know but I think
it depends on people's needs so if you
don't matter I'd like to keep with the
docker file and then we can talk later
about that without a problem
yes that's that's one of the main yeah
yeah so okay so the idea with the docker
file whatever you you have okay mmm who
has managed to write something or like
to clone the repo okay so we'll keep
going like that so now on the goals that
we will run this container in this
container where they will do it will run
the ipython notebook so but you need to
build it [ __ ] sorry ok so the command to
build the containers build you can give
it a name so let's say I call it just
this you have to give the path to your
doctor file so wherever your docker file
is so you just give the the path to it
but you don't specify the docker file
itself that clear I mean a quicker
example just go just sit into the
directory where the docker file is if
you already there it's fine then so now
dr. build- t4 to give it a name let's
say i'll call it just be mg oh I'm sorry
I'm just gonna so can swear it's sort
and then dot to say that here right then
you didn't now for you will probably
take more time maybe depending on what
you have stone is that clear so the
comment again is darker build so I make
that small dr. bill minus T and B or
whatever you call it the name the tag
and that working I mean if you
downloaded the repo i recommend you can
do the Jupiter one it should be the
quicker setting that cool so did you we
have managed to build it you have the
image on is it like a like a fake ID
image movie now you can kind of convert
from this so you're part of this game
just as well in the schedule is
dependent or every for the grammys on
the stand we wasn't in please this is
qualified this you never give it like a
you say from scott brown's yeah it
builds from the better image you specify
so okay now if you do docker images you
list your image so you should have this
here I've DNB okay so because we're
going to probably run out of time so
let's run it run darker run now minus D
let's just follow on like moms dear what
sir eston detach mode and then sorry I'm
forgetting them I'll just one sec ago
did
can view the logs of the container right
now I have no running and usually I just
rather yeah exactly yeah that's cool
yeah here so that's a real command you
can run you can call it whatever you
want minus these four detachment minus
piece to use the ports whatever ports
are specified if you look at the docker
file we expose 8888 minus V is to
specify some volume so if you have a
directory where you have existing a
notebook say so if you clone the repo
you can like so PWD you and then
wherever the pad to din on your host
where the notebooks are if you want to
reuse existing notebooks Colin /
notebooks and then this was foreign then
you need to give the name that you gave
to your docker image so that the tag so
and what I've just built so dr. run mine
is d minus P say
okay so they did anyone manage to run
that but not not exactly depends on
right let me go back to the slide e you
can you can or you you don't have to you
can give a name to that that that's a
container the important thing is a minus
D minus P minus V evenly you can omit
the minus V for this example right now
and instead of anaconda notebook you put
the name that you gave when you do when
you did darker build minus T that that
tag it's the name of the image right yes
yeah so I mean let me show you so okay
so now we're running this now how do you
go and access that so depending on
because I run on the if you're running
on the unpaired index then you can just
use localhost for me because I'm running
if you're running on the Mac you need
the IP of the virtual machine so you can
do boo to darker IP or whatever you're
using but you need to know the IP of
your virtual machine so you can ssh into
it or do I have configured something so
now if I go there this and the port no
no you need to that darker Maps the port
so it's 88 in the content or but as I
don't but the thing is act for you to
access it you need the port to which its
Maps 03 through for you you need to
check you when you do dr. PS PS it will
list and there's a column called port
and then you see in this case it's 32768
or you can do darker port and the name
if you gave a name to your container or
its ID and say I use the ID here then it
will give you the mapping so
at ECPI 32768 so 32768 okay notebooks so
at least if you can achieve that for
this tutorial it's working cool okay so
now we can create notebooks or you can
reuse a notebook if you have the repo
depending let's say yeah I had bigger
intentions but I get there and I guess I
don't know whatever you want and not now
like the thing to may be linked to back
to a question like for instance an
example of how this would be useful this
is that if you have you need to work
with the side by stack and you continuum
even provides a darker image so you can
have the entire anaconda distribution if
you want in a docker container or
whatever you want you know I Python as a
side by stack or whatever you need you
know some but now okay that's I don't
have example that's not the really deep
personal but so we have a working
notebook now let's say you were doing
okay if you destroy the container and if
you're not careful you will lose these
notebooks because they're in the
container that's why they're mapping the
minus everywhere is it that's why the
minus V comes into play so PwC this is
on your host the current directory
national books whatever you provide of
you have to provide the full absolute
path that thing it depends on your
platform but let's say you provide the
absolute the footpad to where your
director is and this maps to your
container and your containers under /
notebooks so and then right so when you
work in the container inaudible to go
there and then there they're being
actually your notebooks or actually on
your host they're just what's on your
host is being mapped
the container yes it makes a
modification in the container minifig
cool and I install something when I stop
it then it depends and you can use
darker commit and then you can commit
that back to the darker images but if
you're using this tutorial like that
takes more time I and it was but the
thing is I you see vol here the
directive volume / notebook so you have
to be careful the thing is like this
whatever you goes into that when you
commit that knew that container to your
image will not be committed to the image
you lose it so you need to back this up
but if you save files elsewhere then
that are not in volumes that are in the
file system if you want of the container
with image then when you commit that
container to the image then it will be
saved to the image are there questions
yes I've not seen multiple crumbs I
don't know if it's possible but I don't
think I think it's only from one yeah so
quickly to show you let's say now we can
run another container z
well maybe it's useless but the thing i
wanted i would i'd like to show you like
how you can interact with different
containers in between each other so that
would have been the next thing like that
then you're in the notebook and you have
some data storage elsewhere let's say
elasticsearch postgres whatsoever you
can have them in other containers and
you can communicate with these other
containers in various ways one way is
that if you know the the port and IP you
can just like like any like just as
though it was on another server or you
can link the container and then the link
makes it somewhat implicit for the
communication from one container to the
other their environment variables are
automatically set in your that's it a
notebook container there will be
environment variables for where
elasticsearch is or if it's postgres or
whatsoever yeah that's because any
questions now let's say you working on a
specific environment and you want
somebody else to work on the same and
you out and export environment to taka
fries and give it to that's the thing
you so you you build your image you use
your in that image you can one good way
is that you use docker hub but or you
use your own registration if its private
but to make the answer short is that you
would use docker hub and you can use
with github you you push that docker
file to github you set a hook with ah ok
there's the command darker history but I
don't know it won't create it you know
let's say Jupiter notebook
so I need to I guess this is not look
this is first if you do dr. history it
shows you the commands that were used to
build that image okay but this is not
like you're not going to type this in I
mean to do it automatically I don't know
actually I don't know if there's a way
maybe there's a way I don't know yeah
yes of of your image or I don't know I
right now I have approaches it from its
development sandbox oh I security right
now is not was was not a concern for
this for me and as I'm learning darker I
have not dealt with that but I mean
darker is used in production also but
what do you mean exactly when you say
security updates action is there a very
mature it is if you can would not oh
yeah you build a new image here yeah
it's a normal level yes just just yet by
a very small returning she's just a very
basic system
this is our ball that is typically
that's why i also like 640 or own
environment is that a good like yeah
just the app with minimal bare minimum
white runs as possible
you